when Jimmy was in the other day we were
talking about they renewed Crank Yankers
which you just mentioned are you guys
working on that together yeah you are
yeah
so you and Jimmy are back together again
doing [ __ ] yeah he doesn't you know he
likes to do it over the phone you know
he did he doesn't want to have a meeting
with you no I mean when we first started
we had to just sit in an office all day
and you know make calls and come up with
premises and design stuff and it was
super hands-on and now we have some help
oh he's busy I'm busy it's not like
we're locked in a room together you know
cranking out oh sorry old days it used
to be you and Jimmy and you be in a room
together and you guys would really
manage this thing and really it was a
team effort now because you're both big
you got other people running the thing
right well yeah because he's both big
and busy and busy yeah and I'm I'm
medium and busy it's just impossible to
you know sit in a bungalow so you guys
aren't really there you got a bunch of
people who run the thing to make phony
phone calls well you know Chef Boyardee
didn't make every ravioli himself he
oversaw the kitchen why why did they
cancel it in the first place it seemed
to me like it was reasonably popular no
I don't I don't know how I don't know
how Comedy Central works I don't I don't
know how anything works so who calls you
and tells you Frank anchors we want it
back on the air Jimmy called you yeah I
talked to Jimmy about it I don't even
know how it how it came about yeah I'll
take the money